وكم من قبور تبنى وما تبنى
وكم من مريض عدنا وما عدنا
وكم من ملك رفعت له على ما فلما على ما
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اسمه واليه ترجعون خرت الملائكه ساجدين
لله
وقالت سبحان من له البقاء وحده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ولقد قلت لنفسي وانا بين المقابر
هل رايت الامن والراحه الا في الحفائر
فاشارت سيده للدود عبس في المحاجر ثم قالت
ايها السائل اني لست ادري
انظري كيف تساوى الكل في هذا المكان
وتلاشى في
رب رب الصولجان
[موسيقى]
اليوم تجزى كل نفس بما كسبت لا ظلم اليوم
لا ظلم اليوم
لا محاكم للشعب ولا محاكم للثوره ولا
محاكم للغدر ولا محاكم لامن الدوله العليا
انما المحكمه اليوم
الواحد
[موسيقى]
الاسلام لا يحارب يا امريكا
انظري الى روسيا من قبلك
روسيا حاربت الاسلام حتى سنه سبعين ومع
ذلك ظل الاسلام هو كما هو
[موسيقى]
اتقوا النا
ر انه لقول فصل وما هو با
انما هذا الكلام انصار
وبين نور الوعد ونيران الوحيد يجب ان ندعو
الله رغبا ورهبا
[موسيقى]